هذه بداية فصل
جديد للبازلاء ذات العيون السوداء ، فنحن لا نقوم فقط
بالموسيقى والفيديو ، لذا فنحن نصنع
موسيقى وثائقيًا لفيلم قصير
رواية مصورة طويلة الشكل AR V هي
أشياء لم نقم بها من قبل.  الصناعة
لم يروي قصة مكثفة عن
الارتفاع في خريف ما كان من
المفترض أن يكون الهيب هوب في هذا الكتاب المسمى
Masters of the Sun ثم قمنا بوضعه
على الكتاب الذي يأتي إلى الحياة حتى يتمكن الناس من
تجربة  رواية مصورة في
فضاء ثلاثي الأبعاد
بمجرد وجود طفل على المستوى الوطني ، حصلوا
فجأة على فيلم مدته ساعة vr تم تسجيله
مع البازلاء ذات العيون السوداء وهانس زيمر
الآن نخرج في جولتنا
Masters of the Sun ،
وقد تم تعزيز خاتمة هذا العرض من خلال  الواقع المعزز
، حان الوقت لفتح Black Eyed Peas الخاص بك
لتعليمك سعيدًا ، اجعله موجهًا إلى
المسرح طوال الأغنية ، سنقوم
بزيادة الطبقة بين الشخص على
خشبة المسرح بيننا وبين الجمهور بحيث
عندما يشاهدون العرض من خلال
العدسة  من الهاتف الذي
يرونه شيئًا ما  إن هذا ليس موجودًا ،
إنه مثل البوكيمون الذهبي على المنشطات
[موسيقى]